[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we've spent an
awful lot of time over the past few
weeks trying to figure out and then
explain what's happening to our country
at times it's been depressing but it
seems important
at this point it's pretty clear that
nothing is what we're told it is these
are not
protests this is not about george floyd
it's not about
systemic racism whatever that is america
is not a racist country
you are not a bad person for living here
these are definitely not protesters
they're not even rioters
they're the armed militia of the
democratic party they're working to
overthrow our system of government
they're trying to put themselves in
power that's all obvious now it's
genuinely sinister
we're worried about it we've said that
we mean it but in the process of saying
that we may have missed something else
that is
also true as well as highly amusing
these people are idiots for real the
angry children you watch set fire to
wendy's and topple statues and scream at
you on television day after day
are truly and utterly stupid
there's probably never been a dumber
group gathered in one place
in all of american history they're mouth
breathers
they know nothing they couldn't tell you
who george washington was
they don't know when the civil war was
fought probably not even to the century
they say they oppose racism and then
they rip down monuments
to abolitionists they don't see the
contradiction in that because
they have no idea who the abolitionists
were they think it's a band from the 80s
a lot of the very stupidest people by
the way are quote well educated
they have all the worthless credentials
we're told we should want for our
children
they went to duke they work at some
non-profit
they hold a good paying job in digital
marketing at nike
yeah they're supposedly impressive but
they're not impressive at all
they're incredibly dumb they fall for
any lie no matter how preposterous the
more preposterous the more likely they
are to fall for it
and like small children they are afraid
of
in california hispanic utilities worker
made the mistake of cracking his
knuckles at a red light
the geniuses thought he was flashing a
white supremacist gang
sign so they fired him poor guy in
oakland mayor libby schaff who claims
she went to college and law school wow
mistook exercise equipment in a park for
ku klux klan nooses
chef then held a press conference to
hyperventilate about hate crimes
talk about textbook hysteria but it was
also
hysterically funny for people this
neurotic life
is one long horror movie they squirm in
their seats paralyzed by fear
even the simplest and most obvious
decisions become impossible to
make they're too afraid the new york
times just profiled a group of people
just like this sympathetically of course
this group lives in an affluent part of
minneapolis
after watching hours of cnn they pledged
to stop calling the police
calling the police they decided was
racist so they didn't call police
almost immediately hundreds of mentally
ill homeless drug addicts showed up and
erected a tent camp in their park
then prostitutes arrived then caravans
of drug dealers showed up to service the
addicts
people overdosed meanwhile neighbors
cowered in their own homes unable to
sleep
one resident a man called mitchell
erickson found himself cornered by
two thugs who put a gun into his stomach
and demanded his car keys
so erickson finally broke down he called
police
and then he deeply regretted it quote i
put those boys in danger of death by
calling the cops erickson told the paper
apparently not joking for the rest of us
the question is
can people this damage this week
actually run a country
and the answer is no of course not and
we definitely should not let them
but in the meantime we also should not
pass up an opportunity to let them
amuse us because they do